today we'll be talking about how we're
connecting awkward array into the other
component and not the other components
but some other components of the pi data
ecosystem so let's get started here
so um brief outline for the things we're
going to cover today so we'll start with
the components the components being
awkward array
of course and then beyond that we'll
talk a bit about dask and pandas because
we will make new connections between
awkward and ask as well as awkward and
pandas
um and finally we will wrap up with uh
demos for however much time we can we
can fit in at the end of the
presentation
okey-doke so first let's start talking
about awkward array
so awkward array is a library
um to operate on nested variable size
data this sentence here is is straight
out of the readme for awkward array so
folks that have used the pi data
ecosystem are should be quite familiar
with numpy
um and uh the Paradigm of array
programming
uh it is very powerful it's very
powerful in Python and uh with packages
like numpy are great for operating on
rectilinear data sets and uh and you
have a wonderful user experience there
so awkward array brings that same user
experience to being able to operate on
nested variable sized data that is the
that's the the new feature that awkward
array allows you to
um
to analyze nested data
so we'll have a small example here
to really show uh to show how this works
um so here I'm creating an awkward array
this awkward array
is of length three but each of the
elements of this length three array
are it's another list so here we have a
essentially list of lists but inside of
the first element of the array we have
some number of records and the records
have an X and A Y field and inside of
the Y field we have another list so you
can see this nested
data structure here the second element
of of the array is empty and the third
element is another list of these records
so numpy like idioms we can operate on
this array
very with similar syntax do we that as
we would with numpy so in this line here
I'm accessing the Y field of the array
but keeping the dimensionality and then
once I get to the innermost dimension
for the Y field I want to take you know
everything past the first element so
this will look
like so we keep our length three array
here but inside we continue to have the
lists as each element of the outer array
and then we go into the Y field and we
take all of the the first element so you
can see I mean this is a
um you know not a super long code
snippet but we're doing something you
know um relatively technical to to go in
and take the square of what we get from
this slice and
um so if we take all but the first
element of all of our Y in our lists of
course the first one is empty uh then we
have the 2 squared is four and two three
nine and so on so we're able to operate
on this nested data structure
um as as we would with array programming
with numpy
so that that's uh a quick little example
of awkward array
um so just like numpy
um arrays are dynamically typed so
um you have all the power of
um of making an array as you would like
to and in a dynamic programming language
um like python but when you go to
actually execute the operations on them
these operations are compiled so you get
that that performance this is really the
power of numpy but awkward array has has
done something very similar but for
these nested data structures
okay the next component uh for the
subjects of today will be to ask so desk
has been spoken about at Pi data already
but um brief intro desk provides both a
task graph library and schedulers to
execute those task graphs
um so plugging awkward into the broader
ecosystem dasc is part of that broader
ecosystem it's been around since about
2015 so it's been a member of Pi data
for for some time now
so the task graph Library components of
desk
so what desk allows you to do is write
code that looks very similar to the code
you would write for eager programs but
what dasc is doing is it's creating a
task graph that will be lazily evaluated
so the eager program numpy
then we can the equivalent on desk side
is desk.array so with the desktop array
API you can do numpy like programming to
create executable task graphs same thing
for pandas to desktop data frame python
iterables so you know lists and things
to map to desk.bag and then there's also
desk got delayed which allows you to
write custom applications
um so the the main idea here is write
programs in a way that one is familiar
with but don't execute you know the math
that you're writing just build up that
task wrap so that you can then execute
it lazily so this works because desk
collections are chunks are partitioned
versions of those concrete types from
the eager programs so a desk array is
just a bunch it's a chunked numpy array
you have a bunch of small Little Empire
Rays not necessarily though but smaller
numpy arrays than your overall desk
array
um and the desperate
uh represents those and the execution
engine orchestrates how to compute with
them so that's a desk in a nutshell
so a small example here to show going
from numpy to desk we can create an
array of ones one thousand by a thousand
and take the Sum along one of the axes
so this is each of these lines is going
to immediately execute something
in the dash.array version it looks very
similar to numpy we call a ones function
to create the
um to create a task graph that will give
us a 1000 by 1000 array we tell it the
chunks that we like so how how to
partition it and then
um we call the sum it looks very similar
there's some function along the first
axis but the main difference is with
numpy this is going to immediately
execute the sum calculation with task
this is going to add to a task wrap it's
going to Stage the computation of the
sum so we don't actually get anything
until we call compute and calling
compute is when we send the taskgraph
over to the execution engine which I'll
talk about now so very briefly the
execution engines
per desk include both the threaded
scheduler something you can spin up on
your laptop to use all of your resources
so this allows you to paralyze
operations but also if you have a large
data set that doesn't necessarily fit in
your laptop's memory if you chunk it and
operate it on pieces with a task graph
it becomes more tractable and there's
also the distributed scheduler which
allows you to scale up to any number of
machines you can go to the cloud there
was a talk at Pi data this year by Matt
Rocklin where he discussed how to spin
up desk and on clusters
okay so the last component before we
start making connections that we'll uh
talk talk about here is pandas I don't
probably need to talk about pandas too
much here at Pi data uh it's a
foundational package for the pi data
ecosystem and many folks that use Python
to do data analysis pandas is their
first exposure to that so very briefly
you know pandas is for calendar analysis
on data frames so you have
um
a some number of columns these are
one-dimensional series of scalar types
typically so some you know a column of
floats a column of the ends of strings
um and multi-dimensional is possible but
um it's not as uh nice as if you have
scalar columns and it relies on Python's
object type so it's
it's a little more complicated than just
dealing with uh rectilinear data
so a small motivating example
um for uh the connection between awkward
and pandas is if we have a data frame
here two columns A and B A is some set
of integers but B is some set of lists
so we have some variable length thing
in our B column so if we go and access
the B column we see
that we have an object's type so this is
a list and if we try to do a you know
pandas operation on this like take the
mean of the series
it won't work because this is a list
um so there are ways around this um it's
kind of beyond the scope of this
presentation today
but
um what I'm getting at here is it'd be
nice to have a kind of immediate support
for
um for nested structures like this
so the way to go about doing that is
with extension arrays and types so I'll
talk about uh real briefly here while
we're talking about pandas so yeah
pandas has built-in support for adding
additional types of columns
um so as I mentioned there are you know
already existing floats and strings kind
of thing there are things Beyond this
but there are built-in types to pandas
that work really well and pandas allows
you to extend on these so we'll end up
talking about that so I just wanted to
mention the existence of the extension
array and D types
interfaces for pandas
so what is new the things that we've
created we will start with awkward plus
desk
so if you remember the table I showed a
few slides ago
we had four entries in the table and now
we are adding a fifth with dasc awkward
so task awkward
adds a new task graph creation API that
does the same thing that numpy to desk
array and pandas to dash data frame they
map the eager programs to a new
um to a lazy version with desk ask
awkward does the same thing for awkward
array so we have a new task graph
creation API and we have a new
collection we have a partitioned awkward
array that um that allows us to to you
know use all of the heavy work that's
already gone into desk so the reason why
I wanted to talk about the execution
engines is because by making desk
awkward like the other task graph
creation apis like desktop array like
that's that data frame so following that
interface satisfying that interface
we get the execution engine for free so
the execution engines are the part of
desk that really aren't the topic of
this of this talk but because we've
plugged into desk in a way where we're
speaking tasks language we benefit from
desks uh execution engine
just by making the desk array Library
the other new component is awkward plus
pandas
so we've created a new Extinction array
and d-type
on the awkward extension array and the
awkward D type and these allow native
use of awkward arrays inside of pandas
objects so this
um this makes the nested structures a
something that we can stick into a
column in in pandas and we also have
um along with the extension array
um and type we also have a
um and what independent is called a
series accessor which allows us to go
one level deeper even when using pandas
workflows and actually use the awkward
Library itself from a from a pandas
object
so I'll show these
um with a small example here so we have
here A series uh this is the same series
that I showed in that previous little
example
um where in this series we have uh a
list of lists essentially and uh
if we if we import awkward pandas we can
convert this this object this set of
lists into a set of into an awkward
array which remember compiled operations
on these uh dynamically typed objects
um so it will be faster than just a
python list
and also on top of that
um we get uh we get to take advantage of
of awkward's computation engine so here
remember if we tried to call mean on
this series uh before we got a an
exception was raised but now if we take
the mean we get it we get a result it
actually takes the mean of this column
as if the data got flattened so it this
is uh that
case here is taking the mean of one two
three four five six which is three and a
half but
we can also as I mentioned go one step
uh deeper and actually use the awkward
Library awkward has a mean function that
allows you to provide an axis and what
this does is it's going to take the mean
along that first inner axis which is
going to be the mean of one two three
which is two the mean of four which is
four the mean of 5 6 which is five and a
half and it will actually return a
series back so we're staying in pandas
World we're sticking with with pandas
objects but we're able to use the Opera
library and execute these operations
on on a panda series
so that's a small example for um
for combining desk and awkward sorry
appendix and awkward
okay so before I jump into the demos I
did want to mention uh briefly that you
can start using these today so first
official releases for desk awkward and
awkward pandas will are coming out this
month
um because we've been work we've been
collaborating with the developers of
awkward array
um and there's a new major version of
awkward that's going to be released and
along with that these new libraries so
you can install these today their
prereleases available on on Pipi so you
can install them and the first official
releases are right around the corner I
did just want to mention that right here
just in case I uh can't come back to
this because I wrap up with some demos
so I will jump over to the first demo
here it's a little bit bigger
if I can
there we go
I'm gonna have to do this manually
that's okay
okay so I have a notebook here
and what I'm going to do is I'm going to
import dasc awkward and awkward
um the task that I'm going to
investigate here for this demo is I'm
going to be looking at some Chicago taxi
um some Chicago taxi trips so I'm going
to load in some data here in inside the
Chicago data set I just have a bunch of
parquet files over here there's many uh
25 parquet files
um this data set is about a little less
than a gigabyte maybe
um
so it'll be good for a demo so the first
line here
um I'm using task awkward and reading
from parquet this is going to start
creating a lazy task graph but just for
some demonstration purposes in the um in
the demo today I'm also going to load
straight from Awkward
um one little uh 125th of the data set
um so I'll execute that so that was very
fast the the longest time was actually
spent and uh and loading it eagerly so
let's look at our lazy data sets so we
have a desk awkward array
um with 25 partitions we can start to
investigate a little bit we can look at
the fields inside the data set there's
trip information payment company inside
of trip we have some more information
um the time the distance things like
that but we can look at the total
set of columns that were found
um so trip has some nested information
payment has semested information and
Company is some scalar piece of
information
um using the eager data
um this which I
Purpose with an underscore here
we can look at the structure with a
little more detail so inside of trip
have time distance and also in a
beginning longitude and latitude
um I had a time we also have the end
information as well as some list of
points along the path that the trip took
and then information about the payment
um so we have really the point here is
we have nesting we have
um nesting and variable length pieces of
data
um so I will look at one trip
individually that I know has some data
in it so you can see here
every trip has an individual start and
stop and stuff but then there's this
list of differences in longitude and
latitude and so that's how we get
different points along the path
so this is
um
the the data set that we have to we want
to try to figure something out uh using
awkward array using desk operator so we
can look now going back to our
non-underscored data set this Taxi by
itself we can look at the the zeroth
element of the array without computation
and actually get a little bit of
information out of it from this
underscore meta attribute so this will
tell us that we have some we don't know
how long
um array of
um of trips inside uh inside here so
what this is telling us is the zeroth
element of our taxi data set is one taxi
and that taxi has some variable number
of trips and inside the trip
um inside each trip is some variable
number of steps on the path so
let's see if we can calculate the
distance that each path sorry the
distance of each trip using these path
differences so first I will
um do a broadcasting operation so that
the trips beginning longitude this is
just one number but the longitude
difference is that's a variable thing
this is we don't know how many points
along the path got saved and so we can
do this with all longitudes and
latitudes and then here because this is
the Chicago Dax Chicago data set we can
convert to kilometers to make this a
little bit more
um and it's usable and uh and this is
still just building up you can see these
cells are executing immediately I'm
operating on my desk awkward collection
but I'm not no no calculations are
happening yet we're just building up a
task graph
so we can calculate the distance of
these trips
um using a non-array programming style
right because we've got this nested
structure
um our you know first inclination may be
to go and write Loops so here's some
pseudocode for how this would look in a
loop we'd Loop over all of our taxis
Loop over all of the trips for each taxi
and then we'd start calculating some
lengths
um so we'd look at the um in the trips
paths we'd take the you know I plus 1
minus i Points along the X and Y
directions Square those differences take
square root and this would build up the
length for a trip
but we could do this with array
programming so I've written it out here
in three lines so we're taking our
horizontal and our vertical distances so
we're taking all taxis all trips
um take you know all points but the
first subtract those from the same thing
but all points but the last and so this
doesn't care about how many points there
are along the along the path but it's
still at race style programming and so
if I do this with a horizontal the X
distance of Y distance and then take the
square root and then finally sum it all
up
um for each trip because I'm taking the
an inner axis here this is array
programming with with an unknown set of
uh
um pieces of nested data so we could all
we could have written this all in one
line but to make it a little bit more
readable I split into three here
if we execute this it's immediate all
we're doing is staging more calculations
and so we can look to see what our
lengths may end up being it's going to
be some
array of floats where but remember we
have chips per taxi so we have some
number of taxis some number of trips and
then each trip has a length so this is
really going to
be an interesting task graph to
visualize so it's a little busy here
um we have 25 partitions but you can see
all these steps that we built up we're
reading the data
grabbing information from the trip
grabbing information about latitude and
longitude differences doing a
subtraction to multiply more accessing
of the data so this is our task graph
getting built up so let's say
we want to see a comparison between the
distance that we've calculated for the
trips and also some recorded distance
that that was recorded like by the
driver there when they made the trip
um we can make a histogram so here I'm
plugging into another
um we can make a histogram to look at
this comparison so I'm using another
desk
Library desk histogram
um and what I'm doing is I'm taking my
lengths calculation along with the trip
distance that was recorded when the trip
was taken and I'm going to make a
two-dimensional histogram so we can look
at it
so this but because I'm using another
Das library to make this histogram it's
also just a very quick thing we're just
building up the task wrap so now let's
take another look now that we've added a
new step
you'll see
that we have all of our previous steps
but now we've added a histogram so we're
getting this this aggregate this
reduction and aeration here finally
we're on
um on each partition of our data set
we're making a histogram and combining
it with the histograms on the other
partitions too finally get the last
piece of data that we like
so I can
um I can also show one more interesting
thing about this calculation and that is
desk has optimizations to make this task
graph uh to try to simplify the task
grab some and so by writing desk awkward
in a way that desk and desk language we
benefit from this already so we can
optimize this task graph and we can
already see that so many of these steps
can happen on the same node in a task
graph so we see this huge collapsing of
these embarrassingly parallel Parts into
a single node So reading the reading
data off disk and Performing the
calculations
um desk is able to to optimize where
their computation happens
so we go ahead and see what we want to
see here we can look at our histogram so
I've made a little progress bar I'm just
executing this using all the threads of
my computer so right now I'm reading all
the data off disk okay and moving on and
it's starting to do some of those math
calculations and you know depending on
which chunk of data got read first maybe
you already made my first histogram at
this point I'm not sure but then
um here we go the computation is done
and we can look
and here's our trips so along the uh the
x-axis here and our computed distance
along the y-axis we have the recorded
distance so you can see most of them
line up you know they're one to one but
there are a few little blockches in the
data set that uh that maybe could
warrant some some further investigation
but we don't have time for that today
but this is just one little demo of
using desk awkward so in the last couple
minutes because I do want to leave a
little bit for questions I I want to
show Awkward pandas
so here
um I'm going to be looking at a particle
physics data set I've got a little shout
out to the particle physics Community
because they are the uh the ones behind
awkward array
um and I used to do some particle
physics so the uh the thing I'm going to
do here is read in a data I'm going to
import awkward pandas
um for those pandas are awkward I'm just
going to go ahead and read in my awkward
data set
um so here I have an awkward array I can
look at it real fast I have some nested
data I'll say a few more things about
this in a second but I'm going to go
ahead and convert this into an awkward
series I'm going to name that series
nested this is what one row of the
series looks like
these are some events in a detector so
there's the detector run the event
number which span of event taking a data
collection was happening but then we
have information about the particles
that were
um that were seen in the detector but
there's
um there's some variable number of muons
in this data set we don't know how many
muons of one particle that can pop up in
the detector and each event can have you
know zero muons four muons we don't know
and those muons have different
properties they're they're trajectory
um so this data set has nesting so we
can look at our series and yeah you can
see there's some and that's the
information in here but what we can do
is we can use awkward pandas to unroll
this into a data frame but with this two
columns method on our accessor and what
this does is it converts the scalar
things into regular columns but keeps
the nested structure that it couldn't
convert into a standard pandas column it
keeps that in an awkward column so we
can look at our data frame now and so
now if you you can start using run
Luminosity login you can start using
those as you normally would in a pandas
workflow
um
and so you can go in and see that we
have a regular Panda series here
um
and there's also the ability to jump
down lower level into into the data
itself we can actually get down to the
awkward array by passing down
um the from the nested column into its
value into its data and so the
um we're getting to to use Panda's
workflows but have all the power of
awkward and still be able to dig into
our awkward data if necessary so we can
make a series that's just the muon's
component of our data set
and one thing that we could figure out
is how many neurons we have so the old
style would be taking the length of each
muhan row uh and looping over the the
muon column so this takes a little while
and it's still running still running
still running
um and because we're doing a python for
Loop here
but we could use it just finished but if
we use the awkward accessor we can use
an awkward num function along that inner
axis to get an immediate result and they
are the same and we have a muon total
number of muon Series so we could then
use that by adding a new column to the
data frame so now we have a new column
here we could limit ourselves with
dataframe.query to only those with two
events and then we can
um you know make sure make sure our data
frame only has when and muons equals
equals two and finally we can apply a
function to
um to the nested piece using the awkward
accessor to make a histogram and there's
for anybody in the audience that does
know the zebos on there's the zebos on
Peak Okay so
I rushed to the end of that demo there a
little bit because I did want to leave
two minutes for questions but uh that's
it and I'll jump over here one more time
just to say thank you for attending
here we go
thank you Doug let's uh give it one
minute to see if there's any questions
uh you have certainly cut it quite close
in terms of questioning time yeah yeah
I'll uh I'll have to jump over to
Discord